ein mildes urteil im sogenannten
betonplatten prostituierten mord von der
weser nachdem die drei täter die 19
jährige andrea k erst zur prostitution
gezwungen und sie dann wie müll in der
asse entsorgt hatten müssen sie jetzt
nur für 83 und zwei jahre ins gefängnis
wir blicken noch mal auf den fall
befolgen und unsere reporterin vor ort
sprechen
andrea k aus niedersachsen 19 jahre alt
mutter von zwei kindern kaltblütig
ermordet ihr lebloser körper wird aus
einem seitenarm der weser nach dem ort
balke geborgen sie ist nackt ihre hände
auf dem rücken gefesselt an ihren füßen
eine betonplatte gebunden
[Musik]
einen familienangehörigen am 28 april
vergangenen jahres findet ein
binnenschiffer die leiche von andrea
kahlen der weser zu diesem zeitpunkt
gehen die ermittler davon aus dass die
zweifache mutter noch lebt als sie unter
wasser gezogen wird sie ertrinkt andrea
wird opfer eines grausamen mordes mit
hochdruck sucht die polizei nach ihrem
mörder es gibt sogar eine belohnung in
höhe von 5000 euro der fall führt die
ermittler ins rotlichtmilieu haupttäter
soll der 40 jährige stefan k sein ein
mutmaßlicher zuhälter aus nienburg
erlebt nur knapp 20 autominuten vom
tatort entfernt tablett aus diesem
zuhälter ist ein brutaler zuhälter ist
nämlich gehört so dass auf eine hölle
schmoren das wünsche ich mir auf jeden
fall
im zuge der ermittlungen werden drei
weitere verdächtige festgenommen einer
ist der wegen zwangsprostitution bereits
verurteilte diego de der ex-freund von
andrea er soll sie für 2000 euro und für
den erlass von drogenschulden an stefan
k verkauft haben damit sie anschaffen
gehen kann als das nicht klappt will
stefan k gemeinsam mit zwei komplizen
die frau loswerden
laut kriminal analytiker handelt es sich
hierbei um eine sogenannte mich
situation es gibt anzeichen für eine
beziehungstat aber auch klare bezüge zur
illegalen prostitution dieser mord war
nicht impulsiv oder aus einem streit
heraus spontan passiert der hass der in
diesem verbrechen deutlich wird deutet
auf eine persönliche verbindung eine
geplante hinrichtung und aus diesem
grund fordert die staatsanwaltschaft
lebenslange haft für stefan k und seine
komplizen problematisch für die anklage
es ist nicht mehr eindeutig wie und wann
andrea kam ums leben kam sie wurde
vorher in einer garage gefangen gehalten
dort wohl gequält und gewirkt weil sich
die genaue ursache für ihren zweifellos
gewaltsamen tod nicht klären lässt
quittiert die staatsanwältin auf
versuchten mord durch unterlassen das
urteil ist gerade gefallen
[Musik]
ja und bild reporterin christine wahl
war bei der urteilsverkündung mit dabei
christian ist es ein sehr mildes urteil
geworden wir haben die richter das
begründet
genau das urteil wurde um 10 15 hier vom
richter verlesen und das strafmaß ist
für alle drei angeklagten sehr sehr
unterschiedlich ausgefallen also der
haupttäter wurde zu acht jahren haft
verurteilt
mit der begründung ihm wird vorgeworfen
schwere zwangsprostitution
vergewaltigung versuchter vergewaltigung
nötigung und körperverletzung durch
unterlassung die beiden mittäter sind
jeweils zu drei jahre und neun monate
haft verurteilt freundin bzw zwei jahre
und neun monate haft wie hat der richter
das begründet es handelt sich hierbei um
ein rein indizienprozess zahlreiche
zeugen die im laufe des prozesses hier
ausgesagt haben haben sich immer wieder
in widersprüche verwickelt diese
aussagen konnten also nicht gebraucht
werden teilweise sind zeugen hier sogar
alkoholisiert und unter drogen
erschienen dementsprechend waren auch
diese aussagen einfach nicht relevant
mehr für den prozess eine vorsätzliche
tötung hat die kammer hier
ausgeschlossen
weil aufgrund der indizienlage konnte
keinem der täter als kann der drei täter
die hier angeklagt waren zugeordnet
werden wer andrea nun wirklich getötet
hat deswegen wurde auch von einer
lebenslangen haft einfach abgesehen was
der richter jedoch in seiner begründung
fest gestellt hat ist dass andrea k
nicht ertrunken ist todeszeitpunkt war
die garage aufgrund von äußerlichen
verletzungen geht die kammer hier von
erwürgen aus
wir haben heute morgen ja auch schon mit
dem bruder der ermordeten andrea
gesprochen der natürlich sicher eine
hartes urteil erhofft hatte gab es
irgendwelche reaktionen jetzt nach
dieser urteilsverkündung
der bruder von andrea hätte sich
sicherlich eine lebenslange haftstrafe
für alle drei täter gewünscht das ist
jetzt hier nicht eingetreten bei der
urteilsverkündung war er sehr ruhig er
hat sich das genau angehört er sitzt
auch jetzt immer noch drin und hört sich
die begründung des richters ganz genau
an die die angeklagten haben auch keine
reaktion gezeigt aufgrund natürlich von
corona muss natürlich auch jeder hier im
gerichtssaal eine maske tragen was
natürlich auch die reaktionen die
gesicht im gesicht natürlich auch etwas
erschwert auch wahrzunehmen ist ich
denke aber und ich bin davon überzeugt
dass gregor der bruder von andrian nicht
zufrieden ist tatsächlich mit dem urteil
weil er hatte mir zuvor bevor der
prozess losgegangen ist auch noch gesagt
er hätte sehr sehr schlecht geschlafen
erzittert am ganzen körper er hätte
lebenslänglich bekommen er muss ein
leben lang damit leben dass seine
schwester so auf so eine grausame art
und weise ihm genommen wurde und er
meinte auch er wird sich eventuell auch
in therapie begeben müssen
glaubst du dass die nebenklage dass die
familie noch mal in revision gehen wird
wenn ja wie stehen die chancen
das ist aktuell tatsächlich schwer zu
sagen also gerade läuft noch die
begründung
das landgericht hat vorhin gesagt es
wird mindestens zweieinhalb stunden
dauern bis urteil und begründung hier
abgeschlossen sind also bis 12 30 13 uhr
dann wird man sich sicherlich einmal
zusammenfinden nebenklage
auch die strafverteidigung wird sich
noch mal mit den angeklagten
zusammensetzen man wird sich in einen
raum zurückziehen man wird die
urteilsbegründung vorlegen wird die
beweislage dagegenhalten und dann muss
man tatsächlich abwägen ob es hier
nochmal sinn macht in revision zu gehen
so ein prozess kostet natürlich auch
geld und es soll muss auch finanziert
werden von daher werden natürlich
strafverteidigung beziehungsweise
nebenkläger natürlich auch noch mal ganz
genau schauen macht es sinn hier noch
einmal in revision zu gehen
[Musik]